Florida's Space Coast
the only thing that Rivals the power of
its Rockets
is the terror of its depths
in 2003 10 horrifying shark attacks
leave beachgoers reeling
investigators must uncover the cause
before it's too late
in 2003 science writer James Hathaway
takes a business trip to Florida and
brings his family along we were here at
Cocoa Beach we were here to watch a
launch for NASA it was a Mars launch and
the kids were mainly here because of
course it was cool Beach
Cocoa Beach lies south of Cape Canaveral
along a stretch of Eastern Florida
coastline dubbed the space coast
Surf and Beach culture are here at the
Space Coast it has a lot of history with
a lot of contests a lot of Shapers and
the reason why so many people do love
the beach and the waves here is because
it's warm it's Sandy Bottom each year
millions of tourists flock here for Sun
Surf and rocket launchers
but visitors looking up may miss a
threat down below
when I am in the water I'm always aware
that sharks are there
I think they are out there and they
don't really want to be around people
and they like to just stay on the
periphery they like to keep you guessing
but they're a hundred percent the boss
I've seen guys with bites from their hip
down to their knee everybody surfs and
the etiquette around sharks is pretty
much keep your hands and feet up and
wait for them to go away
a lot of people can surf here their
whole life and never even notice a shark
that doesn't mean that the shark's not
nearby but people who are watching for
them pretty much going to see one sooner
or later
from species considered harmless to
humans like the nurse shark with
thousands of tiny serrated teeth the
basking shark with its wide open mouth
and the lemon shark
to some of the world's most dangerous
sharks
like the bull shark
these species all swim here
when you live along the coast in Florida
shark attacks come with the territory
there are people today out swimming in
the speech behind me and there are
probably sharks out there
so you know we all take our chances
it was a gorgeous day it was this
beautiful sunny beaches full of people
and the kids were playing in the surf
splashing in the water are James's three
young daughters including 12 year old
Hannah
after 45 minutes James joins them my
wife told me to go out and call him back
because they'd gotten a little ways out
so I went out to get them and I said
come on guys time to go back but before
James reaches the girls something else
does
a big wave broke right over us and the
shark just literally was in the way it
was right in front of me it's about four
or five feet long it surprised me
because it was right in front of me I
went whoa
James shouts to get out of the water his
older daughter's head for sure
Hannah stays behind wanting to know what
her dad saw Hannah was very insistent
about knowing and was jumping up and
down and just insisting that I tell her
but it's too late
Hannah obviously she goes out
something bit me
got close to her she lifted her leg up
and blood was really coming off her
it was streaming down her leg it was a
very clear bite-shaped Mark James gets
Hannah back to shore
soon paramedics arrive you know how it
is with kids so you you don't want
anything ever bad to happen to them ever
and because of all the people around she
said Daddy am I going to die
at the hospital doctors use 13 Staples
to close Hannah's wound
and she makes a full recovery
I feel lucky that his live and okay
after this because frankly she could
have lost her legs she could have it
could have hit her femoral artery and
she could have bled out on the beach
at no point did I ever even think that
there would be a shark in the water you
like assume that you have to be deeper
like you have to be a surfer or swimming
in the middle of the ocean you don't
think that there's going to be like a
shark in like shallow water
to this day honestly every time I go to
the beach
it's like kind of always on the back of
my mind that like there could be a shark
in the water
Hannah's frightening encounter makes
headlines
typically along Florida's Space Coast
attacks are rare but in 2003 she's not
the first victim or the last
10 shock attacks in just eight months
that's nearly the same number of attacks
in the previous decade
combined
locals and visitors alike demand answers
I do remember 2003 and I do remember
there being many reports of shark
attacks that year I think sometimes
there's more that happens that isn't
even reported 2003 was our year of the
shark because we had 10 recognized as
shark attacks which was the leader in
Florida at that time
suddenly reality breaks and you're
dealing with the fact that hey sharks
really do bite people people really do
encounter this this happened to my child
what's behind this terrifying spike in
attacks
perhaps the identity of Hannah's
attacker holds a key to its motive
it's about four or five feet long
couldn't quite tell brownish
Dr Dan Huber of the University of Tampa
investigates
now we're looking at Hannah's scars here
18 years after the attack happened so we
have to try to make an inference from
what the scars look like now to what the
damage would have been back then in
2003. now what we can tell is that these
are the teeth of the upper jaw of a
shark the teeth from the lower jaw of
the sharks that live off the east coast
of Florida are much more needle-like
they would have left individual puncture
marks whereas here we see more of these
slash marks which are the characteristic
of the upper jaw teeth the wound was
also described as being very very
symmetrical according to Dr Huber these
characteristics implicate one of two
possible Suspects
first the bull shark bull sharks are
fast powerful and aggressive often
head-butting their prey before going in
for the kill
they're found in Shallow warm Waters
like Florida
but one key detail points to another
attacker the symmetry of the wound makes
us lean in the direction of a black tip
shark
black tip sharks often feed in small
groups and are easily identified by
their black tipped fins
they attack with speed and can grow up
to eight feet long
now one of the most interesting things
that we find about blacktip sharks is
that they're involved in these large
migrations up and down the east coast of
the United States in order to stay in
water of a preferred temperature
shark expert Dr Stephen kajura has been
studying black tips for more than a
decade each year he Witnesses this
species take part in one of the most
awe-inspiring Marine phenomena on the
planet every winter down here in South
Florida we have an annual influx of tens
of thousands of black tip sharks that
migrate down here and spend the winter
from January through March
this is the largest shark migration in
U.S Coastal Waters as many as 12 000
blacktips swim from Coastal North
Carolina down to Southeast Florida to
spend winter in warmer water and in
March they begin their Journey North
again
and the Space Coast is directly along
their path
here we have a map of satellite
detections from black Dev sharks that
have been instrumented down here in
South Florida in the wintertime and in
the winter months down here you can see
that the sharks are off uh Southeast
Florida and then in the spring March and
April here in the light green you can
see them off the Space Coast Area here
different shark species migrate in
search of food warmer Waters or a mate
and typically they do so in deep Waters
but the potential problem for beachgoers
is that the black tips prefer the
shallows
these sharks hug the shoreline they stay
right up against the beach right where
the people are and as a result you've
got the potential for a lot of
interactions between these sharks and
humans
anytime there's an influx of sharks in
an area
the chance of encounters with humans
also increases what's interesting is
you've got this strong spike in
abundance of these sharks off Central
Florida to Northern Florida in April
which corresponds to the time when you
have this spike in in bites as well
in 2003 simply the result of this large
influx of sharks
the answer comes down to timing
the migration passes the Space Coast in
the spring and again in the fall
but only eight of the ten attacks took
place during that time period this alone
cannot explain the spike
there must be more to the story
perhaps the answer lies not in the water
but in the skies above it three two main
engine start zero and liftoff
thank you
we were there to see the Mars River
launch
2003 was an eventful year for NASA
from April through July when eight of
the ten attacks took place
eight Rockets blasted off from Cape
Canaveral
that's more than the number of launches
that took place the previous year during
these months
could this human space exploration have
unintended consequences for sharks
Dr Huber believes the answer relates to
how a shark uses its sense of hearing
even though you can't see external ears
on a shark like we have they have
internal ears just like we do the
hearing mechanism is buried into the
base of the skull and in this Central
area right here the skin isn't quite as
tightly attached to the skull and that
basically acts like an eardrum that's
how the sound waves are going to enter
into the shark's head when sound waves
reach the inner ear tiny hair cells
vibrate sending signals to the brain for
interpretation
sharks use their Keen sense of hearing
to hunt
some species can even detect sounds from
several miles away but not just any
noise sharks are able to hear
particularly at low frequencies
sharks are sensitive to low frequencies
the sounds that are made by their prey
but can sharks confuse certain sounds
made by humans with those of a fish and
come looking for a meal
the sounds that would be given off from
the rumbling engines of rockets being
blasted into space is low frequency
sounds
could the sound of rockets
unintentionally attract sharks and lead
to the attacks
Dr Stephen kajura explores this
frightening possibility right now we're
off the coast of Southeast Florida today
we're going to be playing some low
frequency sounds in the water this these
would be the same sorts of sounds like
you would get for instance if you had a
rocket launch
and here's the amplifier that I will use
to power the speaker
and now it's ready to deploy
as the speaker begins to broadcast
a drone Scouts for sharks when we see
sharks getting close to the speaker
we're going to turn on the speaker play
an underwater sound a post low frequency
sound and the Drone is going to film The
response of the Sharks when they detect
that sound
that they're attracted to it or repelled
by it or whether they just ignore it
when we put low frequency sounds into
the water we would expect the Sharks to
probably be attracted to them but Dr
kajira's research reveals something
surprising when playing those sounds the
Sharks typically are startled by the
sound and will jump and swim away from
it the reason it seems is volume
though rocket launches are low frequency
they're also incredibly loud a rocket
launch that's so much louder so much
beyond the realm of what a typical sort
of struggling prey would sound like that
it would probably have the opposite
effect it would startle the sharks get
them away from the area
so they're nowhere near the source of
that sound
a rocket launch would have no impact on
these sharks biting people
something else is behind the 2003 Spike
maybe it's not about what sharks are
hunting but rather what's hunting them
the attack on the space Coast's first
victim holds a clue
Damien Cher is a local artist he's been
surfing these waters for more than 30
years if I had to describe the culture
in this area I'd say that everybody
surfs
so catch the waves learn the etiquette
and have a good time
but in 2003 Damien's good time comes to
a halt
I got to the beach was actually around
seven o'clock in the evening there's a
lot of daylight left and the wind of the
day had died down so caught a few waves
and was paddling out with one of my
buddies a few feet away there is a huge
splash
I've noticed behind him the tail end of
a truck just go like this as fish
scatter in both directions
I told him Zach I better stop paddling
that thing just went right under you he
didn't see it and he kept paddling I saw
the shark go under his board
give me an acts quickly to save his
friend
I slapped the water thinking I can just
distract the shark for a moment and make
it not notice him
and I distracted it but the relief is
short-lived
it hit me like a lightning
it felt like somebody hit me with a
baseball bat
the shark just raked his teeth across my
arm opened it up wide the force of the
impact was amazing and it just knocked
my arm out of the water
I looked down and I saw a hole in my arm
and that's when it started to bleed so I
hollered Zach it got me
I knew I needed to get out of the water
because I was worried that this Blood
would attract more sharks
and we rode the next wave into the beach
together
back on Shore Damien grabs a towel I
knew I needed to compress to control the
bleeding and I grabbed the towel and cut
my arm up you know above my heart Damien
is rushed to the emergency room where
doctors use more than 40 stitches to
close his gaping wound here's my Shark
scar starts this far down my wrist and
works its way up just about to my elbow
I could have lost my arm I could have
lost my life
Damien becomes the first of 10 shark
attack victims along Florida's Space
Coast in 2003. an alarming Spike over
the previous decade
but the species behind Damien's attack
May provide a break in the case
I saw the whole tail end of thing come
Splash out of the water so there was no
mistaking what kind of shark was in in
my presence
this shark was around seven feet long
the batter is really tight and it's
beautiful it looks like a tropical fish
I could see the pattern of a tiger shark
Dr Huber investigates Damien scar to
confirm the ID
now independent of his observations when
we look at the scarring on Damien's arm
there's also evidence of it having been
a tiger shark because the scar is very
very flat different sharks have
different shaped Jaws some sharks have
more curved Jaws but as it turns out
tiger sharks have very very flat Jaws at
the front of their mouth and this rather
straight scar that we see right here is
really a type of Scar that could only be
left behind by a tiger shark
people who spend their entire lives
swimming tend to know the sharks that
are in the waters that they swim in so
there's a decent chance that he
correctly identified the attacking
species
tiger sharks are named for the vertical
stripes found mainly on juveniles
with their sharp serrated teeth they can
easily rip through turtle shells and
discarded tires
if a tiger shark bit Damien that at
least two species are responsible for
the spike including the black tip for
bull shark that bit Hannah
there's all kinds of sharks in the water
here you can be out there not see any
sharks and then all of a sudden you've
got sharks sometimes more than one all
around you
when you're in the water you realize
just how it the whim of sharks you are
and where sharks would be chasing one
another away or if multiple species got
into the same area they might get into
some kind of turf war
is it possible that different shark
species are in direct competition for
food and humans are simply caught in the
crossfire
Dr Michael hydehouse of Florida
International University is determined
to find out if an inter-species Turf War
exists in Florida we're heading offshore
of Palm Beach Florida so we can try to
find multiple shark species in one spot
to just see how they behave when you mix
more than one type of shark
within members of the same species
sharks seem to coexist peacefully
for example black tip sharks tend to
spend their time with the same group
each day
and even work together to hunt
but does this civility hold true between
species
Dr height house and marine biologist
Francis farabaugh dive deep to find out
Florida is an amazing place for sharks
because there's so many species we might
see here you might see black tips Bonnet
heads lemon sharks great Hammerheads
tiger sharks bull sharks so this is an
area where all of those might mix
over a dozen lemon sharks swarm the
researchers
named for their pale yellow skin lemon
sharks congregate in large groups and
can grow up to 10 feet long
you see they have no sense of personal
space they kind of nudge into you but
never any aggression
but when a bull shark arrives
will the lemons defend their turf and
cause an undersea brawl
we had a big bull shark just kind of
come up out of the depths do one Circle
no Behavior change in the lemon sharks
the bull shark kind of shrugged its fans
and said uh this is not worth it and
just sunk back down into the Merc
throughout the experiment the lemon
shark's Behavior remains consistent
while they were excited and curious and
maybe up in your personal space they
weren't aggressive or territorial they
never bit us or any other sharks even
though there were plenty of sharks in
the water and more than one species
the thing that we saw today that really
fits with everything I've seen
throughout my career with sharks is that
they tend to be very calm
big sharks will eat small sharks but
when it comes to that kind of fair match
battle they're not really territorial
you didn't see two species come together
and their behavior change and they got
more aggressive towards people that just
doesn't happen
when you think about Predators on land
mammals like big cats wolves coyotes we
think about territories you know they're
set areas on the land that are kind of
defended from other Predators it's their
spot that really doesn't happen as often
for sharks in the ocean
um
and part of that is why would you bother
defending a fish school that by the time
you've defended it some other Predators
come in and eaten it so you don't tend
to see that territoriality
a turf war is not what caused this spike
in attacks in 2003.
strange spike is linked to a different
mysterious incident from 2003.
another attack is about to unravel a
mysterious clue
in 2000 here on the Space Coast we
started kind of documenting the shark
attacks in 2003 Wyatt werneth is the
ocean rescue chief for Brevard County
2003 was our year of the shark because
we had 10 recognized as shark attacks
which was the leader in Florida at that
time
but for Wyatt one attack stands out
he was a surfer that I knew
so that made it a little bit more
intimate I knew the guy
the 21 year old Surfer prepares to catch
a wave
but his ride is cut short
clamps down on his left foot and shakes
back and forth
the surfer manages to break free and
head for sure
but the damage is severe
so when I got down to the scene
they were applying a tourniquet with the
rash guard
blood everywhere
the rash guard started out white and was
red by the time we got to the ambulance
the surfer's left foot is seriously
injured
but after surgery he recovers
the pain that he was exhibiting that
still resonates with me I swim in these
oceans all the time and I flash back to
that episode where that guy someone that
I knew all the pain still is in my mind
to this day
but there's something
serving about that day that Wyatt can't
forget
and the two events may be related
in 2003 on the Space Coast during the
time that we're having all the shark
activity we were trying to figure out
why and how what was causing this
and we did discover just before the
attack that there was an orange slick in
the water something that we hadn't seen
around here before this so it was very
uh mysterious to us
this so-called orange slick was a patch
of discolored water a few yards from
Shore
the nature and source of the Slick are
unknown
causing officials to temporarily close
the beaches
what is this suspicious orange slick and
how might it affect sharks
Wyatt wonders if the unusual occurrence
could be linked to a red tide
red tide is what we would consider an
algae bloom and that algae bloom does
have a negative effect on marine life as
well as humans
Florida red tide is triggered by an
algae that can cause Coastal Waters to
appear reddish or brown
is an orange slick the same as a Florida
red tide
Dr Tracy fanara who studies algae along
the Space Coast investigates Florida red
tide is endemic to the Gulf of Mexico
it's only made its way up to the east
coast about nine times throughout
history in 2003 was not one of those
years
the fact that an orange slick was seen
before one of the shark bites could be a
huge clue but this was not a Florida red
tide bloom
not red tide what caused the orange
slick
this outsized question might have a
microscopic answer I just took a sample
of water from the Indian River Lagoon
we're going to look for algae
the Indian River Lagoon is an estuary
that because of currents and water
movement can bring nutrients pollutants
sediments and harmful algae into the
coastal Waters of the Atlantic Ocean
today the water sample shows a healthy
Lagoon
2003 data reveals that this same area
was teeming with pyridinium
pyridinium now this is a harmful algae
species it's responsible for
bioluminescence people come from all
over the world to see this algae because
at night it actually looks like a blue
glow but during the day it looks like an
orange slake
and this algae does more than just turn
the water Orange
pyridinium bahaments releases a toxin
called saxotoxin which is a neurotoxin
that impacts fish including sharks
this neurotoxin can have serious
consequences for any animal or human who
consumes it
foreign
people were getting sick from eating
puffer fish that were plagued with
saxotoxin from the Indian River Lagoon
and there aren't many species that can
actually consume puffer fish
one of those species though is sharks
if consumed by a shark could this toxin
potentially affect the Predator's
Behavior some fish aren't affected right
away but eventually with enough toxin
they start to swim in a circle kind of
like they're losing their ability to
navigate
could sick sharks have lost their
ability to navigate
and accidentally swim in Shore
where they encountered people
is this the cause of the 2003 spike in
attacks
something doesn't add up
there was only one orange slick reported
it's very unlikely that it was the cause
that they increased and shark bites
perhaps the answer to why the sharks are
biting can be found by analyzing the
nature of the bites themselves you can
see where the teeth kind of like sunk in
it's in the shape of a mouth Hannah
Hathaway was just 12 years old when she
was attacked by a black tip or bull
shark off of Cocoa Beach
it was really crazy because the shark
literally just came and just bit me and
then swam away and I hadn't even been
doing anything
Dr Huber revisits the bite mark photos
of the Spike's youngest victim Hannah
Hathaway
in Hannah's case the scarring is
consistent with a grab and release sort
of attack because there's one series of
bite marks so the teeth sank into
Hannah's leg a single time there's no
evidence of repeated biting there's no
real evidence of head shaking back and
forth to try to remove a chunk of Flesh
it was a single bite the teeth went in
and then apparently that was the extent
of the attack
based on this single bite
Hannah's father has a theory to explain
her attack it was a big enough shark if
it was hungry for what it was attacking
that it really could have taken the
chunk out of her it's very clear that
the shark just tasted her does taste
really factor into why a shark would
attack
and could it be that they simply
disliked the flavor of human flesh
the Predator's Anatomy suggests it's
possible
it's been suggested that sharks may be
tasting their victims and then deciding
about whether or not to continue the
attack
while humans have taste buds that are
concentrated on our tongues sharks
actually have taste buds that line the
entire inside of their mouth the tongue
area as well as up through the roof of
the mouth and even onto the gills in
some cases though numerous these taste
buds are incredibly small
if we look inside the spiny dogfish's
mouth really really close we can see
there's a series of little bumps that
line the roof of the mouth and also the
floor of the mouth and each of those
little bumps is a taste bud
but before a shark tastes it will try to
smell hear and see its prey
sharks use a lot of different sensory
information before they take a bite out
of a prey item in order to decide
whether or not to eat that particular
thing
and when they eventually do take a bite
that bite is that last piece of
information that they'll use to decide
about whether or not to eat that
particular thing now whether or not
taste really plays a role in that
decision making process is a bit unknown
to attempt to find out Dr kajura put
shark taste to the test what we're going
to do is we're going to present to the
Sharks a couple of different food items
we're going to present to them fish that
they would typically normally eat well
they're also going to present to them
some pork which is visually similar but
it's not something they would ever
typically encounter in this experiment
the pork simulates human flesh
the reason we're testing with pork is
because apparently Pig tastes very
similar to humans based on what
cannibals have told us and so we want to
see what the sharks are actually able to
consume the pork or they in fact bite in
and spit it out
the sharks in the tank include sand bars
black tips black noses and nurse sharks
to my knowledge no one has tested
whether sharks are able to distinguish
between a fish and a piece of pork it's
going to be interesting to see what they
actually do
the food is offered to the Sharks
through small feeding holes in a safety
wall
first up
fish
without hesitation the sharks eat the
having the Sharks literally feeding
right out of your hand that was uh that
was incredible Dr kajura next offers the
pork but will the sharks bite
[Music]
I think that we saw a couple of the
Sharks actually consume the pork and
then spit it out
but uh whereas one shark would spit it
out another shark would then consume it
for the most part the sharks ate
everything they were not picky at all
they would eat the pork and the fish it
really didn't matter
the test provides no clear answers about
the taste preferences of sharks
I think one of the factors to consider
here is that these are captive animals
and they're accustomed to being fed
anything they're fed is something good
for them basically and you contrast that
out in the wild what the sharks are
probably much more particular about what
it is that they're eating out there they
are probably not accustomed to certain
things and when they encounter them it
makes sense that they would spit them
out and ignore them
scientists draw a firm conclusion about
the role of taste in the spike
in response to a shark attack people are
going to fight back we're going to punch
and scream and kick and it's most likely
that the reason the shark went away was
because of Hannah's reaction to it and
not because the shark had tasted Hannah
and decided that it didn't want her
cannot explain the surge in shark
attacks along the space coast
but one thing this Theory suggests is
that sharks are heavily motivated by the
presence of potential prey and one of
the victims in the spike witnessed
exactly that
[Music]
we noticed there was a lot of bait in
the water you could see birds diving out
of the sky chasing the fish could see
big fish jumping after smaller fish
the ecosystem was alive
I think my arm just looked like another
fish jumping in the water
if a shark's already in a frenzy chasing
the bait and you paddle in there that
your arm just looks like a fish jumping
could the shark have mistaken Damien's
arm for a fish
Dr Hubert takes a closer look
right now we're looking at a slide of a
mouse's eye because we can use the
retina of the mouse's eye to have a
better understanding of how shark Vision
Works as we zoom in on the retina at the
back of the eye we can see what are
called rod and Cone cells now the rods
and cones are the photoreceptors which
are actually responsible for absorbing
light and then activating the nervous
system so that the brain can interpret
that as images
cells that give the human eye the
ability to see in color
but in a shark's eye something is
missing in order to have color vision
you need multiple types of cone cells
now sharks typically only have one type
of cone in this layer which means that
they typically don't have color vision
so sharks generally speaking have black
and white vision and they use that black
and white Vision to see their prey items
in contrast to the surrounding light
that comes through the water
this means that a shark's vision is
highly dependent on the clarity of the
water
if it is murky minimal light is able to
penetrate the water resulting in a
blurry image
this is key because the waters where
Damian and the others were attacked can
be murky
foreign
the answer for the 2003 Spike suddenly
becomes clearer
ocean scientist Dr Tracy fanara
demonstrates how murky water could have
played a role in the Space Coast attacks
aquarium tank we have clean water
aquarium tank we have water taken from
the coastal Waters around Cape Canaveral
now this water is colored and turbid
because we have organic matter coming
into our Coastal waters on top of that
we have a lot of sediment close to the
shore making this water really dark or
murky
here we have two swimmers this one in a
monotone gray and this one with high
contrast in this experiment the high
contrast swimmer represents Damien's arm
in the water or a shark's prey many Bait
fish have different contrasts they'll
have a white underbelly and a colored
body or different colored fins or they
might even be striped and sharks have
evolved to be attracted to this contrast
to be better predators
so as you can see right now you can see
both very clearly in the clean water but
when we bring it over here to the murky
water you might be able to see the
swimmer with the high contrast a lot
clearer than the monotone Gray
in the case of Damien's attack his arm
could have appeared high contrast
similar to bait fish
so it's very possible that a shark might
have misidentified Damien's arm swimming
through the water as bait fish
especially if he was swimming through a
group of bait fish
in addition to blending in with the bait
fish Dr Huber believes Damien's actions
confuse the shark when a shark came to
investigate those Bait fish Damien
became concerned that his friend was
going to be attacked so he slapped the
water and in this benevolent action to
draw the shark's attention away from his
friend he drew the shark's attention to
himself which is what led to the attack
this Theory May hold water
but when the data is analyzed
investigators find that Damien is the
only victim who reported fish nearby at
the time of the attack
there has to be more to the story
perhaps the answer lies not in what the
Sharks were doing at the time of the
attacks but rather what the humans were
doing
investigators are about to crack the
case
I got to the beach caught a few waves
and was paddling out with one of my
buddies
analysis of the data reveals that like
Damien 70 of the victims were surfing
when attacked
the activity that I would most associate
with shark attacks on the Space Coast
would have to be surfing
coincidentally a huge surfing Festival
was held in April of 2003. the same
month that six of the attacks occurred
this Drew large numbers of visitors to
the area
and that's not all
we were in Cocoa Beach
we were there to see the Mars River
launch
The increased number of rocket launches
in 2003 also Drew hordes of Spectators
to the area further crowding the beaches
you know having big events like rocket
launches or surfing competitions can
bring more people to the beach and put
more people in the water more people
coinciding with an annual Springtime
shark migration
could these events have put sharks and
humans in the same Waters at the same
time along the Space Coast you have not
only these seasonal pulses of migratory
sharks moving by North and South but you
also have residents who are there year
round so you have black tips you have
spinners you have Dusky sharks you have
Sandbar sharks there's a large number of
sharks in that area so as a result you
have large numbers of sharks in the
water at the same time you have a bunch
of people in the water
anytime there's an increase of humans in
an area
the chance of an encounter with sharks
also increases
is this the final piece of the puzzle
look around the world really the
shark attacks is the number of people in
the water
the 2003 Spike comes down to a
convergence of events that puts more
people in the water
it's all about that random Collision of
sharks and people and bad luck
a long-awaited answer for residents and
survivors alike I feel like every day I
wake up I'm lucky to be alive especially
participating in a sport that has its
own risks and having an incident where a
shark actually touched me definitely
feel lucky to be alive for sure I I'm
definitely grateful that my dad came out
there I think it just the entire
experience felt a lot safer knowing that
he was there if something worse had
happened I don't know how I would have
gotten out of the water the wall is
really unusual and unlucky situation to
have this happen once it did happen I
think we really lucked out and that it
wasn't much much worse this was one of
those moments where everything could
have changed in an instant
these are rare events but when you have
rare events sometimes you know you flip
the coin and you get all heads other
times it's 50 50 or all tails and I
think you know sometimes that's what
explains years that have more bites I
know it's the most boring answer of all
time but bad luck happens
spikes and shark attacks can often
indicate something that has changed in
the ocean which often has to do with
human impacts we can use these attacks
to better understand our impacts on
ocean systems and as more people crowd
the beaches around the world
investigators worry shark incidents will
increase as well
[Music]